[Music]
this is Star Talk this is a things you
thought you knew Edition and that means
it's just going to be me and Chuck for
this whole episode can you can you
handle it Chuck
no I'm already I'm
overwhelmed because I already know that
I don't know see oh oh okay there's no
thinking there's no thinking that I know
okay so we're gonna uh let's first take
on a topic that's so simple why do
things break when they fall what do you
think of
that see but this is this is what I've
learned yeah from things you thought you
knew there are times when in the past at
full disclosure where you have said so
we're going to talk about floating
things that float and in my head I will
say not audibly of course uh but I will
say Neil has lost his damn
mou he wants to sit here and waste
people
time talking about why something might
float and I'm like all right bro
whatever let's okay let's get into it
and then we start talking about it and
by the time it's over I'm like oh my God
okay so well so here you go let's let's
do it okay why things break when they
fall yeah
so uh maybe it's obvious to some people
but just I thought I would tease out the
physics of what's going on okay all
right okay so you have a plate that is
up on a shelf okay right it's a
breakable plate all right and somebody
shoves the plate it falls it hits the
ground and breaks it's a cat a cat did
that a cat did that for sure it's always
a cat for sure okay one of my favorite
memes was it a meme where they said we
know the Earth isn't flat because
otherwise cats would have pushed
everything off of it right now I never
saw that but that's hilarious that's a
really good evidence that Earth is not
flat all right so the plate is in front
of you you actually have to commit some
kind of violence on the plate to do it
okay okay so what you have to do is ask
how much energy is holding this plate
together okay all right so you go down
to the molecular level and see how
strongly the molecules are Bond abound
to each other okay so in a crystal for
example they're pretty strongly bound
together so if you try to break a
crystal it's hard takes more energy to
break a crystal all right and so but a
fragile sort of dinner plate all right
not a plastic plate but just one that
can break you actually have to put
energy into it and the plate will not
break unless the energy you put into it
is greater than the binding energy of
the molecules holding the plate
together okay okay that well and that
makes sense that's simple doesn't that
make sense it makes complete sense what
I what what what doesn't make sense
right now is binding energy okay so well
I thought those two words mean exactly
what you think they mean in that
sentence so the two molecules that are
adjacent to each other all right now why
doesn't the plate just separate all by
itself by itself yeah something is
holding the molecules together okay it
could be any one of a number of kinds of
forces doing it but nonetheless they're
attached to each other and if you
introduce energy that's greater than the
energy that's holding together you will
break break that Bond gotcha okay so
that's how anything breaks basically but
we're Happ to use dinner plates for this
example all right so if it's just
sitting there in front of you and if you
pound on it you'll break it all right so
you had to put energy in it but wait a
minute the plate that's sitting on a
shelf that the cat pushed off you're not
pounding on it you didn't pound on the
plate nothing touched that plate okay
did the cat break the plate no the cat
just showed the plate the edge of the
shelf and even if the Cat broke the
plate you know cats they' have been like
I ain't break your
PL I don't even know who you looking at
why are you even looking over here first
of all why are you in my house right now
that's what I'm trying to figure out who
the hell are you and why do you why do
you show up every day how'd you get a
key is what I want to know how did you
get a key to this
house well can I get back to Breaking
plates please anyway anyway so the cat
didn't do anything to the plate the cat
didn't physically break the plate right
okay so what broke the plate this is the
question you know that if you take a
hammer and hit it to a plate it'll break
you know if you pound your fist on the
plate it'll break you know all this
okay why did the plate break when it
fell off the
shelf because it hit the floor
okay yes yes
okay uh okay
um it hit the floor with a certain
amount of energy correct yeah okay and
the higher the location it falls from
the more energy it's going to have does
that make sense of course yeah and you
know what kind of energy that
is uh energy of motion so we have a word
for that kinetic kinetic energy exactly
so the kinetic energy of the plate that
it had the instant before it hit the
floor you have to ask how much energy is
that compared to the binding energy of
the
plate all right and so does that exceed
The Binding energy of the plate and if
it does the plate will break okay where
did the plate get its kinetic energy
from um gravity gravity okay uh or right
but gravity didn't put the plate on the
Shelf okay who put the plate on the
Shelf well I mean I mean who who lives
with the
cat that's who put the plate on the show
yeah cuz you know okay so so the plate
used to be at a low location right and
somebody walked up to the plate after it
was cleaned it was like the lower shelf
of the dishwasher they picked it
up used their energy aha to give that
plate what's called gravitational
potential energy okay and the higher you
put the plate on the Shelf the more
gravitational potential energy it has
and then the plate just sits there in
possession of gravitational potential
poal energy it just sits there and if
you dare if the cat pushes the plate off
the shelf the gravitational potential
energy swaps and becomes kinetic energy
right okay until it has no gravitational
potential energy left which is right
when it hits the floor and all that
energy becomes
kinetic and this dance between kinetic
energy and gravitational potential
energy is is what goes on in every curve
and every turn of a roller
coaster okay R other than the first pull
up the top right okay where there's like
chains and Motors everything else is
free fall basically you're in free Glide
all right and so that's why when you go
up a hill you slow down well why are you
slowing down because the gravitational
potential energy is taking away your
kinetic
energy and and once you get to the top
why do you speed up on the way down
because the kinetic energy is taking
away is is being converted from the
gravitational potential energy and your
fastest point on an entire roller
coaster is going to be
where the fastest point yes you mean
where you reach your top speed yes
where's that going to be uh the bottom
of the first drop the bottom of the
lowest point of the roller coaster is
going to be your highest kinetic energy
and your and your and your highest
potential energy is obvious now it's
going to be to be whatever is the
highest point on the roller coaster
right so the roller coasters fully
exploit this gravity kinetic energy
potential energy relationship okay and
all I'm saying is you want to know who
broke the plate you did because you gave
it the energy to break in the first
place by ascending it to that shelf see
sounds to me like you've been talking to
the
cat cuz that's something the cat would
say I had nothing to do with this what
you talking about whoever
put who put it here it's their fault
right I was just introducing you to some
gravitational kinetic energy okay
getting rid of some potential energy and
by the way the broom is over there
okay okay so let's keep going now
suppose the plate fell from an even
higher height okay all right it just
doesn't break into two what happens oh
it shatters it shatters egg unless
there's some other sort of structural
aspect of it like like safety glass
shatters rather than just breaks into
large pieces that you know why it's
called safety glass because the pieces
are are so small that one piece can't go
in and like cut your jugular right
you'll just be like surface damage to
your skin uh with safety glass that's
why it breaks into very small pieces
like instantly it's so it's what so it's
death by a thousand shards instead of
one instead of just one big one that cut
you in have that put pierces your aorta
all I'm saying is that if it's higher it
gains more kinetic energy because you
gave it more gravitational potential
energy and by the time it hits the
ground it has much more energy to bake
the to break the plate with so it
doesn't just break it in three places
it'll break it in a 100 places there it
is nice so that's why things break when
they
fall I have to say
once again I'm
impressed gotta tell you right now uh
you know I thought at the end of this
talk that I was going to feel like the
cat like what the
hell wait wait so and and just to be
clear you could make something if you
wanted to say I want to make a plate
that doesn't break right all right so
you make sure the binding energy between
the molecules of the plate is greater
than the energy that would that it would
be given by the cat if it fell off a
very high shelf in your home and it's
basically unbreakable for most things
that would happen in your home and so
you could you could calculate what that
energy is and find a material substance
for which that's the case so that's
where you get break resistant say yeah
break resistant stemware for clumsy wine
drinkers
yes uh so the the material substance of
it has higher resistance to it requires
more energy to break it than what is
normal and typical for a delicate wine
stem I had a job where I had to uh
demonstrate something that was
uh build as unbreakable at the time MH
and when you're you were supposed to
demonstrate it within
reason okay I took it and slammed it
down and it
exploded and I then said to the people
uh maybe it is break
resistant and that was your first and
last day on that job oh oh oh without a
doubt you kidding me all right so there
you go Chuck listen here's the one thing
I know now the Earth is not
flat that's thank you that's what okay
that's if that's your only takeaway
that's a start that's a
start all right we'll be right
back Chuck you ready for another one oh
yes okay this is the topic of white
noise you
know don't go there just stop I'm just
saying since since January 6 now that we
bought it up I did not bring it up now
that we bought it up I got it's just you
know since January 6 is happened
why while we're on the
subject White Noise right was long
defined before the chaos at the capital
okay all right so uh White Noise is what
is
described as a combination of sound
frequencies that ends up just sounding
like a like a
hiss it's a hiss okay okay right and so
what's going on there as opposed to
black
noise which
is shut them damn kids up that's black
noise y'all know I'm down here trying to
watch my stories the hell is wrong with
you that is black noise black noise that
is black noise thank you Chuck we'll
introduce that to the anals of physics
right all right okay all right enough
enough Sil
so uh so here it is so what it is it's a
mixture of all frequencies of sound oh
wow all all at once all audible
frequencies of sound okay okay you could
add in others but it won't make any
difference because you can't hear them
okay so white noise is low frequency
middle frequency high frequency and
there different ways you can do it
because high frequency sound at the same
amplitude actually carries more energy
so
you you might sort of adjust it so that
you have the same amount of energy uh
Sound Energy in each sort of frequency
band all right so there different ways
to Define it the point I'm making is all
samp all frequencies of sound are are
sampled and what that sounds like to you
is a hiss it's
like okay so they say which it's so
unfortunate now that we live in an age
of Digital streaming and cable
television because kids will never get
to know what White Noise sounds like on
their tele when you're between channels
when when TVs were were actually
grabbing uh radio frequencies from the
air right with the with the antennas
right if you were between channels or if
the channel went off the air you would
see static on the screen and that would
sound that would be the sound of white
noise yes oh oh by the way by the way
by by the way uh some fraction a few
percent of the hiss that is on that
screen uhhuh is the cosmic microwave
background oh that's hot as opposed to
the world where carolan was taken in
Poltergeist
oh right I'm not authorized to speak
further on places such as
that so so so that's what it would look
like if you made sort an image on a
screen but that would be oh by the way
that would be electromagnetic noise so
that's not audio yes they turned a radio
signal into an acoustic signal right and
that acoustic signal comes across as a
hiss as a white noise all right so cool
that's so cool just to be clear about
that so now you have to ask why is it
called White so here's where it comes
from if uh Isaac
Newton uh one day uh the sun is shining
through his window
and he closes his curtains or or cuts a
hole in the W forgot which might have
done both and just one narrow beam of
sunlight comes through the wall okay
then he takes a prism a 60 60 60
equilateral prism okay okay and he puts
the sunlight through the
prism and on the other side of the prism
comes the rainbow right the colors red
orange yellow green blue violet okay
but he had a mystical fascination with
the number seven and those six colors
don't sum to seven so he added
one which which color did he add Indigo
Indigo of course so we have red orange
yellow green blue indigo violet all
right and that spells everybody's friend
Roy G Biv okay we all love Roy G Biv yes
so there almost as much as B Biv
Devo
that was
good b b Dev only knew had a cousin
called Roy G bib If Only They
do so um so anyhow so it has all the
colors there okay right so the question
is did the prism create these
colors because the white light is no
longer visible
right and this is what everyone presumed
of course it created the colors because
if they were there before it entered the
prison the prism you would see them we
see them of course so so then he said
well what'll happen if I take another
prism put these colors back
through let's see what then comes out
the other side you know what came out
the other side white
light and so Newton was very clever not
just because he was smart but clever in
his experiments and what questions to
ask and how to adjust the experiment to
test for things where you it could be
one thing or another but let's readjust
the test to distinguish what explanation
might account for it in so doing he
showed that white light from the sun is
composed of equal amounts of all the
colors in the rainbow in the Spectrum
and by the way rainbows people said oh
the raindrops are making the not the sun
it's in the sunlight this is freaky how
could color be in white light what the
hell is going on okay well you got to
get into the physiology of the retina
and the brain and all of that the point
is your eyes are
racist
that is how all the white all the light
is
white all the colors come in to your
racist eyes and all they see is white
I'm afraid I have to just say that is
the physics to the
truth there it is that's the physics of
it so the the point is if you combine
all those frequencies of light the red
the orange the yellow the green the blue
The Violet and combine them all and you
have equal amounts of them all you get
white
uhhuh
so this word word in that context was
then Borrowed by the sound people ah if
you put equal frequencies of
sound okay it's not a thing it's just
this noise we shall call it white noise
even though the sound unless you're
synthetic where you have cross-wired
senses the sound is not a color all
right but we assign we say it's white
out of homage to Newton and the colors
of the spectrum and the fact that you
put all these colors these different
frequencies together and you get the
color white so that hiss is White Noise
for that reason yeah you know and it's
funny because it is I I understand that
the the the borrowing of the term that
makes sense be just because it's the
same picture of what you plus you're
using
frequencies frequencies right sound
waves light waves the whole deal fre
makes sense but the the the the term
doesn't really fit for like you say
unless you're uh you know uh you have
synesthesia it doesn't fit we need a
better term for white noise is what I'm
saying
okay okay so the point is noise can be
any combination of those frequencies but
when it's equal across the board only
then is it white noise that's no why
can't it be equality
Noise
Okay Dei noise diversity Equity there
you go diversity equity and inclusion
noise that's what it's doing that's
inclus and we can call it Day Day noise
dayi noise right now there are let me
tell you something right now there are
some Fox News viewers that are watching
us right now and their heads are
exploding their heads are exploding
right now Bill Mah just threw up right
yeah because he's anti-woke that's oh
yes he's so anti-woke but yeah no it
makes perfect sense honestly to to
borrow that uh that picture but it's a
very specific kind of noise it really is
otherwise it's not white noise for
example if you had more red in your
spectrum than blue and you mix them
together the object will have a red Hue
to it okay and if you have more blue in
the mixture rather than red it would
have a blue hue to it in fact red stars
and blue stars in the sky are exactly
that they're giving you all frequencies
but they lean towards those the that
side of the spectrum that has those
colors so um I I think it's okay to
borrow terms that make sense in other
context I don't have a problem with that
yeah it it Paints the picture I mean you
know from the new the problem is not too
many people know the Newton story that's
my point is that yeah you know I mean it
makes perfect sense once once you
explain the Newton story I'm like oh my
God that that's awesome you know like I
get it now white and if your acoustic
noise is Clank clanky clanking or or if
you can find any signal within that
noise it's not white noise it's not
white right exactly yeah that's it's
very cool though okay so I thought I
just set the record straight there once
again I'm impressed that you took you
know something totally
stupid made it made it super
interesting and and informative I got
I'm tell you something I don't know how
many times you can pull this
trick what I I don't want to hear later
on that you come out with a with an
album black
noise oh my God that should be my next
album black noise noise that is good
that's good that's a good name for an
album that's all that could work that
could work black noise black noise you
heard the White Noise here's some black
noise there you go shut the hell up
right don't make me put my foot up your
ass there you go that's more black
[Laughter]
noise all right we got to end and by the
way what say this what what black noise
and white noise make perfect sense
together okay okay it's just like what
the hell is going on what how many times
I would tell
you man shut the hell
[Laughter]
up white
those they belong together they belong
together oh man so Chuck you ready for
another segment absolutely okay so let's
take a quick break and when we come back
the third and final segment of things
you thought you
knew we're back Star Talk things you
thought you knew Edition these are fun
Chuck I like I like doing these love it
I I I I prefer having a guest because I
don't like being the center of anything
but I'd rather showcase the expertise of
others but there's these dangling holes
in in all of what people know and think
is going on on in the universe and and I
just got to patch him up I like it I
think it's more fun when it's just us oh
okay yeah I mean I like guest too but
you know this is
nice
okay actually I'm lazy and I'd rather
like the guest I mean the guests do all
the work right because is their
expertise we're tapping right but but
there there are certain things in the
world that uh are incomplete in people's
awareness of how things work and so well
the fun of this is that it it goes to a
place where you would not logically
progress yeah exactly there's no step
right before it and say let me go there
right because too many lanes and routes
and off-ramps around it and so and we'll
just put we'll stand right in the middle
of the
road excellent all right okay so here it
is the topic things to do with wormholes
uhoh
watch out I just thought you know I
don't know man I don't know if we should
be doing this people are not imaginative
enough that's my point why are we going
why are we giving people let me explain
no
scientific um sci-fi writers right now
are watching this here yes and going bro
get a pen yes Neil brass Tyson is about
to hook us up with some
ideas on what to do with wormholes do it
my point is we should be getting paid
for
this we this is valuable all right so
here it goes uh so let me remind people
what a wormhole is yes all right so we
have the sort of the fabric of the
SpaceTime Continuum all right so it's
not just that space is out there space
is in
intricately configured with time and and
how do you know this because we did this
exercise before I think we did SpaceTime
in in another in another show we did an
explainer on that where I ask you I say
Chuck let's have lunch um let's have
lunch tomorrow okay let's have lunch
tomorrow at 12:00 noon okay and then of
course I will say are you
buying okay that's that's not what I
thought of course of course it's well
where want to have lunch yeah so the
question is where all right so I set up
a time and you knew that was incomplete
right and we have to complete the the
engagement by establishing a location
right so I gave you a time tomorrow
12:00 noon and you're going to say where
all right and I might say you pick
whatever but we need a wear otherwise it
doesn't work all right I could be in a
place at a different time or at the same
time at a different place but we have to
be in the same place and the same time
in order to meet okay right and on on
the same token I can say oh I'll meet
you at Gabriel's for lunch okay and then
you say what time all right all
so space time are forever
conjoined for this fact okay and other
reasons but this is that's the that's
the terrestrial one that is closest to
how we think about the world all right
this fabric can be distorted in such a
way that you can change the distance the
SpaceTime distance between two
locations okay all right and one way to
imagine that is imagine all of our
universe is just on a flat sheet of
paper and you're on one edge of the
paper and I want to get to the other
Edge and I'll take out light years of
time whatever however long that takes
okay it's light years distance so I take
many years traveling at the speed of
light but if I take the space and warp
it curve it back on itself mhm now your
location is very close to
me if I could somehow punch through the
fabric of space and time and reach your
location that's the warp drive right
there well well so the warp drive would
accomplish that by other means but it is
nonetheless warping the fabric of space
the fabric space making something that
would otherwise be longer a shorter
distance and thereby transcending the
speed of light to do so you're no longer
limited by the speed of like the
diameter of our galaxy is 100,000 Lighty
years you can't travel across it unless
you figure during the TV commercial
unless you figured out a way to warp
space and time okay so in that warp in
principle on paper you can have a hole
that you pass through and just come out
the other side and you're in another
place and if you did it right you can
show up at another time but let's just
make your timeline continuous with
yourself so you go right through and you
come out the other side bada bing there
you are that's the most classical
invocation of a wormhole MH okay and by
the way in spite of what Hollywood shows
that when you go through wormholes it's
like you go through the the water slide
at the water park no that's not how it's
just you just step through right and
you're there right this is accurately
captured in in Doctor Strange all right
where he opens a portal does he do they
call them wormholes in no they don't
they call them portal yeah just a portal
and that's a wormhole and but in Rick
and Morty they do exactly the same thing
and he know they're wormholes that they
know this okay and the difference of
course is that in Rick and Morty they're
using real science to make their
wormholes whereas Doctor Strange is
using magic magic yeah yeah yeah and you
got you got to you know do your fingers
in a way and go in a circle and the
little sparkly on the edge of it too
right right definitely weird looking
idiograms that they yeah somehow somehow
have power and okay so so things to do
with wormholes all right yes you can
move through space and time just as has
been portrayed in the film but let's get
a little more practical okay so uh the
movie Monsters Inc was all about
wormholes did you see Monsters Inc you
have kids you saw Monsters Inc I did
several times I've seen that the doors
yeah I see what you're saying they're
manufact curing doors that the monsters
take home and then they open the door
that is the door of the closet of the
kid they have to scare that night that's
right okay and there's a big chase scene
where they're going in and out of doors
in the factory and they show up in Paris
and they show up in in you know in 20
different places with every door they
pass through those are wormholes so
instead of a transporter which
molecularly deep I'm getting there
you're exactly right Chuck that's my
next thing so my point is if you just
walk through a door you walk through a
door okay that's the Wormhole and what
while they never said it in Monsters Inc
which is a Pixar Disney Pixar animated
feature with very cleverly done and it's
and they're funny um they didn't say it
but those are wormholes period period
okay without the the histrionics of a of
a doctor strange and without The Madness
of Rick and Morty they wormholes okay
well if you have wormholes and you can
warp space in that way then the
transporter in Star Trek which
dematerializes you beams your energy at
the speed of light to a location and
then you get
rematerialized right would be completely
unnecessary yeah exactly you just po the
hatch walk through now you're in the
other spaceship now you're on the
planetary surface why' you have to take
me apart exactly you completely took me
apart bro completely yeah okay plus
there was some episode I was told maybe
in the later series because I'm less
complete in the later series that
there's some fraction of your molecules
that are not transported accurately yeah
there's like an copying errors yeah
that's well that's why they have the
buffer it's called The Transporter
buffer system because of that it
compensates for that which is why
sometimes which so lazy but it I love it
it it works it's like somebody gets lost
and they're just like Well what we'll do
is we use the transporter buffer to take
all of their molecular imprint and then
we'll just make another make bring the
person back oh okay okay so they don't
they don't really die in a pile of goo
okay exactly all right so so what's
interesting there is we're in the age of
information which was not so in the
1960s right and they didn't weren't
thinking about information in the same
way or at all and so all you really need
to do is make an an exact copy of all
the information that is contained within
you all the neuros synaptic
configurations and everything and then
beam the information to another ship and
then recreate you there and then what
that means is I can create you in any
location and I can create multiple U's
that's right and I mean why not they do
that with the with the replicator all
right that's right that's all the
replicator does that's all it does so in
principle if you have a replicator you
don't need a transporter system okay we
just have the information of Who You Are
and transport that but so that's one
thing you would do with a wormhole okay
so we have monster scaring children
that's first
application second I love it CU
otherwise how otherwise how they going
to get in your in the kids' room there's
no way they can get in exactly another
thing is imagine if the back of your
refrigerator were connected to your
grocery oh wow he stock it the same way
he stocks the shelves at the grocery
store at the grocery grocery store they
take a peek oh you you low on lettuce
and the lettuce is turning bad they'll
take out the lettuce put in a fresh one
and there is no Transportation Network
involved say goodbye GrubHub the the the
and yeah so GrubHub is is a is a
practical Wormhole right by the way you
know what else a wormhole is another is
an
elevator oh think about it you walk into
a room the door closes and then when the
door reopens you're in a completely
different time and place that's actually
kind of you know you know yes that think
about that just if if you before
electricity and before elevators and
before tall buildings just grabed
someone off the street and take them
into a modern elevator oh my God and
then the doors you know they they're on
a street level or something and then
they push a button and then they open it
up and there 100 stories up and they'll
freak out how did that happen the room
didn't change I didn't see anything
there were no windows what happened so
for me an elevator is a modern sort of
next best thing to a wormhole that you
can come up with yeah right you could be
in one room and then take an elevator
and then there's a kitchen and another
room and then it's like a living room or
whatever you know and and so just the
world changes just in a matter of
seconds so so what do we have so we have
the elevator is a poor man's wormhole
yeah we got scaring children in their
closet we've got the transporter in Star
Trek we got the back of your
refrigerator and what that ends up doing
is
completely
removing the transportation sector from
the world I was going to say what you
really I'm home for the rest of my
life I don't have to do
anything way you don't have to go
somewhere to obtain something yeah
everything come right through the hole
right through the hole correct correct
and I got one other I think I've told
this many times but I I even laugh every
time I retell it even though it happened
to me and it's my my joke right so is is
that good or bad Chuck are you allowed
to laugh at your own ah listen I I say
whatever works for for the person
telling the truth whoever that's right
so so here I was in the Charlotte
Airport I was and I had to go from a big
plane to a little plane and the carryon
that I had did not have wheels so I
actually actually had to carry it and I
Chuck it felt like I walked three miles
it might have just been a mile but to go
from a big plane to a little plane in
that airport I must have walked the full
width of the entire airport campus and I
finally get to my destination with a
little bitty ass plane and I said I got
to tweet this so I
tweeted can't wait until there can't
wait for wormholes that way all airport
Gates would be adjacent to each
other you just you just step through and
you're there right okay and then because
I thought that was a nice geeky thing to
you know tweeting to my geek base I got
out
geeked okay I got out geeked here it is
uh one of the responses was Dr Tyson the
day we have wormholes you won't need
airports I said oh that is true yes oh
oh
yeah well now you just put every pilot
out of work I know well this is a
Readjustment to the economy that's
happened many times before nobody's
making horsedrawn carriages anymore or
buggy whips or you know there's whole
industries that don't I I don't they're
still making the buggy whips they're
just not for buggies anymore
okay
sh they're just call whips okay fine
yeah yeah yeah fine um so so basically
the entire Transportation sector would
go out of business basically overnight
and it's a fascinating reality and but
and plus you wouldn't need 12 Lane
highways to go anywhere you go you want
to go Grandma's house for Thanksgiving
just wormhole in so so each home would
have like a general purpose Wormhole
that you dial the coordinates and come
through but your grocer they'd only have
access to your refrigerator right right
and and your in-laws would have access
to your friend's house
do not come in here man that I'm G to
tell you something I don't like the
world with just wormholes that's a
little too close no you could lock them
we'll figure out a way to lock them it'
be like your front door okay you you
hear a knock you know no but you can
never get away from anybody think about
it no matter where you are you lock them
out of your Wormhole yeah but then there
then they call you on your worm
phone they're like I'm right here I'm
right here hey man what's going on man
where are you I just went to your house
you're not
home right no I'm in I'm in Bermuda okay
I'll meet you there exactly oh yeah you
that's great I'll be there you a couple
seconds no man this is not cool okay I
didn't think of the downsides of this
plan okay somebody's got to like think
it through a little further than I have
but uh just think or or maybe the
wormholes are where the previous uh
ports were right you had you know uh
train stations airports space ports you
have a wormhole port and so you can't
just go anywhere at any time you got to
sort of sign up and yeah that's a little
better yeah the other Way's a little
invasive you can't even pretend like
back in the day when like you know the
you know people would knock on your door
and be like oh you know okay we're not
answering that in the day you that you
couldn't tell them in advance that you
were showing up right so you had to be
ready to greet someone door in fact the
very word caller was someone who knocked
on your front door and that word was
adopted into telephones and so now we
think of caller as only with phones
right but you know the gentleman caller
for on the lady I do believe you have a
gentleman caller
at my good
deala you did not tell
[Laughter]
us you got your Plantation accent right
on right on you
there okay so Chuck that's 101 things to
do with a wormhole that's lovely I love
it thought I'd tell you about that and
uh so let's call it quits there that's
been the third of three segments of
things you thought you knew hope you
enjoyed that that was fun and as always
I'm Neil degrass Tyson biding you to
keep looking
[Music]
out